I'll make this completely public so if
anyone wants to like save this or add on
to it or clone it or just follow along
people are welcome to or I call this
crushing Danish yeah bit and we'll just
make it completely public I guess so
everyone has full access how to play for
black oh thanks for the cheer docks for
me hundred bits I appreciate it
yeah I'm gonna end I'm actually gonna
end this soon but I do want to uh just
go over this thing so we'll look for box
perspective I'll share the link in the
twitch chat if people want to follow
along but let's go forward and thank you
Nick up for five cheers for one bit each
I'm I'm very appreciative for for all of
the bits people are throwing at me
anyway a Danish gambit for black I don't
recommend accepting the gambit this is
very playable but if you're getting in
this position Bishop c4 or take take it
is dangerous so in this position I
recommend very I consider it like
probably the strongest move and it's
very thematic move for these sort of
positions is to play d5 where we just
challenge the center white will take
take take and now I will say that why it
is usually happy going into this line
because there's a pretty well-known trap
where I'll just show as after Knight c69
of three the ship g4 Bishop e2
it looks like black can win a pot by
just taking on a three in taking on d4
the problem with that is white wins the
Queen after Bishop takes c6 check and as
Queen is left undefended so this would
be very tragic for black and just for
fun let's see how many people are
falling into this me chess over fifty
people over sixty people if I can do
math or sixty people exactly I can't do
math sixty-two people are falling into
this position as black which is pretty
tragic so if you're black I recommend
getting to this position because most of
the time light will be excited that you
might fall into the trap but you don't
take on f3 here you played Bishop b4
check Mike c3 and then and then you play
a move which looks bad based on what we
just saw you play Bishop take f3
Bishop take f3 and White will get really
excited that you it looks like you're
about to take on before and come on to
the same trap see how many people fall
into this another 41 people so over a
hundred people fell into this stupid
Bishop takes you six like opening trick
so what I recommend is ya take on f3
take on f3 and then very very strong
move for black and we can see this is
pretty high scoring 2 gets to play Queen
C 4 and if you remember how to get to
this position it's very pleasant to play
black is preventing weight from castling
black's also threatening Bishop takes c3
so the line continues from here a lot of
the time light will take on c6 black can
take back very important to take with
pawn if you take with Queen you will
outweigh to castle and we don't want
that so you take the pawn Black's still
applying a lot of pressure
threatening Bishop takes c3
and now I think the most common move for
white is Queenie to check yeah Queen you
to check take take and if you take your
opening seriously I recommend just
memorizing this line like remember how
to get to this position will make the
semane line and this position is pretty
common a like close to a thousand games
maybe just under a thousand games I
apologize for my dog barking but but
from this position I recommend knowing a
little bit further
essentially what blacks should do is
target the deep on and it's somewhat
imbalanced because the deep pawns weak
but these pawns look weak too so I
recommend that blacks should Castle
queenside bring the rook to d8 you
should bring the Knights very important
to bring the knight to e7 and then f5 a
lot of times you can double up like
bring the rook to d6 and other Brooke to
d8 and then then the bishop from before
usually maneuvers to b6 and it's very
pleasant like if we see this play out
let's say Castle just go through the
most common moves 97 I showed this to a
student and my student actually had this
position in a tournament recently and
plate Knight f6 which was unfortunately
not the right move but 97 much better
Rock HD 1 and yeah the H rook can also
go to e eights just looking very
pleasant I might choose 95 Knight to f5
here looks a bit more flexible and then
decide whether to play like play to
double up on the D file or to play
rotates and like all of ax pieces have
potential to defend or to attack the the
d4 pawn and meanwhile c6 is going to be
well defended like if necessary if I can
play King b7 so that's the
recommendation for black
against the Danish in a nutshell that's
quick but if you know this line first
remember between c4 secondly just
remember where your pieces should go in
this position one more thing I'll say is
that the whole line that we just saw it
works against the Danish it also works
against the scotch gambits which is
after ministry night c64 taken in c3
it's just going to be a transposition
where that plays g5 here we can we can
just go into the same line white will
take take take Bishop g4 same position
just make a comment here transpose is to
main light it might be good to annotate
this a little bit let me just give Queen
C 4x clam and I'll leave it at that's so
feel free whoever might find this useful
you can take this from me chess you
should be able to clone it like if you
wanted to clone it just click the share
and export and then clone and then clone
the study and you can add on to it so
anyway I really haven't been reading the
chat but hopefully people enjoyed that
whoever plays a five out there I know
people want other stuff but I'm hungry
and I'm I also have like other work to
do so probably what I'll do I'll either
be back later tonight I'll definitely be
back tomorrow tomorrow's approach s
League in which I'm not playing but I'm
a manager for one of the teams so I'll
probably be doing commentary but but
yeah thanks guys for watching and I'll
be back in the future bye